John chyme ESPN NFL nation it covers the
Redskins he joins us now John thanks for
joining us on short notice
what is the latest on Alex Smith well
Dan thanks for having me on first he is
still in the hospital recovering from
multiple surgeries there is an infection
from you know when because of all these
surgeries he does have an infection and
that's what they're trying to to
obviously get under control so still in
the hospital and definitely faces a long
recovery and a difficult one what was
the initial surgery he had well he broke
his tibia and his fibula in his right
leg it was a compound spiral fracture so
the surgery was to correct all that and
the the odd thing in this whole
situation was the comparison to Joe
Theismann and his injury in 1985 and the
weird thing is that it was to the day
and Theismann was actually at the game
and I'm bringing that up because after
the game I talked to Theismann I'm a few
of us too but I've talked to Theismann
and he said well the difference is that
I had the infection and you know I had a
bone sticking out of my leg it didn't
have to worry about the fear of Alex
didn't have it didn't have to worry
about the fear of infection well they
found out as I said that was actually
the case so that's what the initial
surgery was to correct and I know you
know since this is a sports show I have
to look at it from that sports you know
vacuum here of looking at what the
Redskins are gonna have to look at for
the quarterbacking situation here
because I don't want the timeframe is if
there is a timeframe for Alex Smith to
ever play football again
absolutely and that you know damn that
is the hard thing in this situation and
I was talking to guys and lock them
yesterday and you know Trent Williams to
be it was talking with him and he said
you know on the outside people don't
look at this and worry about how we're
gonna do this are gonna do that he goes
we're just worried about Alex and so you
always have to keep that mind but from a
football perspective they are in a tough
spot now after the injury you start
talked to people there and they knew at
that time before before all this stuff
was released that they were going to
have to start looking at quarterbacks in
the draft and when I talk to people they
said you know they would say
what round went round well they don't
know because they didn't know where Alex
the situation was headed and they still
don't so in a few months a lot of things
can change but they know they're going
to have to get another quarterback in
here and partly because Colt McCoy
brokers like new now he should be ok for
the spring in the spring workouts but
that's another fact in the situation so
the problem with this situation with
alex is the camp hit they can't if they
wanted to cut him to free up cap space
after the season it's too prohibitive
they would count around 40 million
against their camp they'd have 40
million dollars dead money if they cut
him this year the real list of time to
cut him would be in a couple years now
they could get rid of the contract after
the 2019 season and still face a cap hit
but it'd be a lot more for him a lot
more palpable than it would be this
offseason so that's a complicating
factor so my guess is they would keep
him on the roster maybe on an IR
situation and then look to draft
somebody and maybe also sign a third guy
to have just in case final topic and it
has to do with Jay Gruden bringing up
the possibility of bringing in Colin
Kaepernick I I wasn't sure how this was
going to be received locally because
you're around Jay Gruden all the time do
you really believe that the Redskins
with that owner thought about bringing
in Colin Kaepernick no no I don't
ok I didn't think so because you know
Daniel Snyder's on record is saying you
know that America says you should stand
for the anthem and I just can't imagine
you were gonna bring him in but if
you're right you know then you're saying
well he's got to get ready in our
offense and all this Mark Sanchez didn't
look ready and is Colin Kaepernick beti
better than Mark Sanchez yes even
without knowing the playbook I'm
guessing that he is even now but I don't
I don't know if there's any future to
this if they look at next season where
they said you know what maybe we would
bring him in to start the year since
you're not sure your state your
quarterbacks in situations in the state
of flux correct and I think you're right
all those points and Jay Gruden did say
you know if it had been week one maybe
you look at it differently I think
from talking to them well you know just
from Kaepernick as a football player
audio stuff aside his point would always
be even prior you know you talk to them
she says the same thing privately they
say publicly that they because of
situation they're in they needed
somebody that they knew and they knew
and they knew what he could do and now
they do have guys on their staff who
have worked with Kaepernick and now you
know so take that for whatever it's
worth but they do have people on the
staff who worked with Mark Sanchez in
New York so they knew what he knew or
and what he they could translate to him
in their off and so that's you know so I
think with four weeks left in the season
that was their comfort point and that's
why they brought in Josh Johnson Johnson
at Ben and Jake ruin system and two
different stops now he hasn't hasn't
thrown a pass in like six or seven years
in a game so you know but that's those
are the stated reasons and I you know
whether or not they how seriously we're
really bringing up I just I think
because of what Gruden said about
wanting some familiar well if that was
never going to be really the case here
so you know yeah he did say if it was a
week one situation maybe you'd do it
differently which would mean then you
could revisit but I wouldn't see it
happening then either John thank you we
appreciate your time thanks for having
me on
that's John Keane ESPN NFL Nation
covering the Washington Redskins for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show at
[Music]